hello
and welcome to the virtual edition of
our year-round screening series
film independent presents i'm rachel
bliemer director of events
um i wanted to welcome you guys to a
very exciting q a
but before we do that i have to thank
some of our partners
and our loyal supporters uh thank you to
the hollywood foreign press association
thank you to vision media our screening
partner and thank you to the los
angeles times our media partner for
those of you watching today there's a
little
question box at the bottom of your
screen please take advantage of that and
ask our panelists questions towards the
end of the
conversation uh with that i'm gonna stop
blabbering
um and welcome and and our very honored
uh guest moderator today
please welcome film critic writer and
editor armaday tinubu
please take it from here thank you so
much hi everyone
we're so excited today to be chatting
about farewell more
it's a beautiful film i'm sure you've
all seen it by now
so we're just going to jump right in to
talk about this gorgeous story
um the first thing i wanted to ask was
equal
how did you come up with the story i
know some of it was in part inspired by
your own family and experiences
thank you um the story is inspired by
an aunt and uncle who were married in
tanzania in the mid 90s
and you know soon after the wedding my
uncle got a student visa to come to the
us
and came with every intention of
bringing my aunt and at that point
they're five-month-old right behind
him and you know to this day in 2020
they've been
stuck in a never-ending cycle of visa
applications and rejections and
applications and rejections and
over the years just watching how their
lives had changed how they had changed
as individuals
in order to remain hopeful that they
would still one day be reunited
i was inspired by the what if story what
if
the visa was no longer the mountain that
they were climbing and
they were able to be reunited where do
they begin at that point
so following along with these characters
and in their shoes
as they discover the new the new world
their new beginnings
now how did you get involved as producer
because it
is very much the story of a homecoming
in a way for this family but they're
also strangers
so they meet at jfk and their world
really exists in brooklyn
at that moment so can you talk a little
bit about your journey into the film
yeah absolutely everyone and i we've
been working together for so many years
we've been friends for even more and uh
when we were talking about just this
experience um
she was writing about it and i just kept
encouraging her to write about it
and uh and we knew that we wanted to
tell this story
as a feature um and we just it's been a
long journey we started in 2016 i think
it was
aqua or 2015. and uh little by little we
produced a proof of concept uh they did
really really well
in film festivals that was the precursor
to
the the feature-length version of this
film and from there we just built up
steam and momentum
and folks who really felt the heart of
the story and loved us as collaborators
and wanted to team up on board and
along the way the the that little engine
that could just kept going and
before we knew it we were and we were
working with these lovely
these lovely talent you know so so it's
just been an amazing journey and we're
really excited to
present the film to audiences this
friday
now before i jump into the talent i
really want to talk about the fact that
this story was told in three parts
so we get walter's perspective we give
sylvia's perspective
and then we get esther's perspective why
was it important for you to show
all those varied perspectives from the
moment they meet each other
until the film uh concludes
um i mean there was a little bit of
indecision um
as far as whose story i wanted to follow
coming out of the short prequel that
heria mentioned
um that had been walter's story and so
walter was the most present in my mind
when i started writing
um but i thought it was a little cliche
to tell a story about a man who had an
affair and
you know him juggling these two women so
i thought well maybe the daughter's
perspective
but as a young black teen
dancing with music then i felt like that
could
just too easily get categorized as like
a black teen dance movie
and i didn't want that for you know
because i feel like this movie is so
much more
than that so then i thought well okay
maybe i'll just do from both of their
perspectives and see what happens
and so you know i spent about six to
eight months writing it from
walter and sylvia's perspective and then
it just became
just abundantly clear that it didn't
make sense to not have esther's
perspective because
her story is a linchpin to both of their
stories and so added that on
but i mean really overall it's just i
was just fascinated by this idea
that even though they're all
experiencing this one big triumphant
event
um they're having very distinct and
unique experiences of the one unique
triumphant event
and i didn't want to dismiss anybody's
experience
you know for the other person i wanted
us to be able to actually walk in each
other's shoes
so as not to feel like we already know
that story and we know what they're
gonna do
and what they should have done but
actually like
walk with them and see what it's like
and natare i loved walters story because
it was so nuanced so obviously he's a
man who's been without his family for 17
years
he hasn't been celibate he's been living
his life he has a new love linda
but when his family comes he tries to do
the honorable thing
can you talk about your approach to that
character and the way that you
understood him
as a man well i thank you so much for
the kind words and i
i think the operative word you said he
tries he tries to do the right thing
and that's where in the drama lies
because untangling the heart
is sometimes one of the most complicated
things to try to do
but what's interesting is that he was
open with linda
about his situation he didn't
present himself as a single man he
presented himself as
a husband and a father
and that he was trying to bring
this family here so it's interesting
that you know the kind of person that
would be willing to
engage in a relationship like that and
then still extract themselves
so i found it you know the story for me
it shows how it is
possible to love two people at the same
time and and how difficult it is to
to do that and the cost it takes to let
go and
what it takes to try to reconnect with
someone um
long lost especially if only existed in
your imagination
which is most the part for his daughter
um
because uh especially a teenage daughter
um which you know there are mysteries on
them
of themselves they're still trying to
figure themselves out
they want nothing to do with their
parents usually
and part of growing up is rebelling
so for me it was really beautiful sort
of complex layered love story
um not just with the mistress but with
the wife and with
the daughter as well and i feel like
it's you know
it's not a happy ending but we see that
they've made
steps closer to get to get closer
together
and i just want to point out that the
fact that linda is
okay with this situation it just shows
how common it is
like when echo and i were making this
film there were so many people
like you know who we told about the film
and they were like oh my god that's my
story that's my
my my family or my uncle or my
aunt you know and so with walter when he
shares the situation with linda
linda understands because you know it's
not something that
is foreign you know to or to be in this
type of a situation and granted the
length is
17 years that's a long time but this is
an experience that's very common
certainly and you get to see sort of how
he knows this one woman and doesn't know
the white that he marries
and what i also found really interesting
is as sylvia and walters sort of bond
esther's left on the outskirts so
tonight i would really like to talk to
you about esther's crisis of faith she's
obviously very grateful to the lord that
she has made it back to her family but
she's also
understanding and wrestling with the
fact that things are not as
expected them to be so can you discuss
that a little bit
um i feel um
in esther's case i feel it's almost a
case of um
i feel somewhere that she was a little
bit surprised
at the you know when she comes upon the
the the knowledge that walter has been
having this other life
um i think it's a mixture of surprise
and disappointment because
i feel that the fact that she became so
deeply religious
almost put her in this bubble of um
naivete and uh
you know thinking she wants this to work
so badly she came over and she had like
stars in her eyes and
you know the romantic reunion and all
that and i think it was it has to have
hit her
i certainly the way i felt esther
i felt that it hit her in the gut a
little bit like a conscious stomach to
think you know i've been faithful to you
all this time
and how could you not have been faithful
to me so
it's uh i could see her struggle and she
needed to have that
faith to hold on to faking herself into
believing everything was going to be
perfect and um yeah and i think ontario
was so perfect for the role because
he's such a romantic person in real life
i mean who says words like untangle the
heart
clary says words like that you know and
like he said and i went this is why he's
perfect for the role
he's such a romantic person anyway and
then and that's what
linda i mean not linda i think that's
what esther remembers of him
romantic that love that had gone away
and she wanted to reconnect with that so
it was a sharp reawakening for her i
think when she realizes oh gosh
things have changed i have to face the
fact that we don't know each other we've
grown apart but we still have this child
we have to find our way back to this
family
certainly and i think for a lot of that
jamie sort of sees the differences
in her parents i'm sorry jamie not jamie
um sylvia she said but jamie how
can you talk about a little bit uh how
you sort of navigated that you see this
young beautiful teen girl
and she's in a whole new country but you
really see sylvia adapt
in a way the teens don't often adapt to
their situations and she does that
through dance
which is something she does have in
common with her father
so can you talk about that through line
and then i i want to pivot also to echo
and talk about
dance as a through line in the film in
general
well yeah i mean um that's a beautiful
discovery that i think sylvia gets to
have
in the film right is um
beforehand dance felt like her own
private experience her own um something
unique to her
right and she gets understanding that
that's something that she actually
inherited from both her father and her
mother
right and what does that then mean
you know as a teenager you're trying to
fit in you're trying to find where your
place is you're trying to find how you
belong and then add on top of that
she's now being brought to another
country she's being reintroduced to this
man that she hasn't seen for over
17 years um so already trying to fit in
and then trying to
reimagine where she fits in her family
right and and digest
this new structure um
so what a gift it is when she learns of
a shared love or shared language between
her mother and her father
um so a lot of the time she's she's just
watching and taking in
information and you know my favorite
part of the film is
when um walter says to sylvia
gives her permission basically right to
be free to to express herself to
to express her art um
and i think she needed that right
because sylvia you know it's funny i
just realized oh yeah sylvia is an
artist
she isn't i i never thought about that
until like
this week um and just in my own life
like what that
means to to get that permission um
to be free um yeah
yeah i mean i think um the
one of the purposes of aside from just
loving and golden dance and music
and wanting to you know have as much of
that
as i could um and wanting to share that
you know with
many people who probably haven't heard
or experienced it
um it you know it is very one of the
things that i love about angkor and
dance and music is that it has very
specific
um purpose you know as jamie just said
you know for sylvia's character dance
becomes a third language for her
as a way of expressing herself and is
very true to the style of dance that she
practices which is kuduro
um which is used by young uncle and
young people um as a way as a platform
for them to
speak about the things that you know
they're concerned about you know in a
society that doesn't have a lot of space
for young people's voices um dance and
music is the place where they're able to
talk about some really heavy things and
what might look on the surface like just
your typical sort of hip-hop dance
style um you know people are talking
about domestic violence and
life after the war and economic
hardships and all sorts of different
things
and then for um walter's style of dance
that he practices which is
kizomba and semba um
those you know are very beautiful
sensual couples dances which
first of all when do we ever get to see
central couples dances from africa
but so wanting to showcase that
but you know unlike other couples dances
salsa bachata
um kizomba does not rely on a regular
foot pattern
and so in order to dance to kizomba
there has to be a level of connection
between the two dancers otherwise there
is no dance because the leader is
merely reacting to the music and the
follower is reacting to what the leader
is doing
so there isn't anything to fall back on
and i just thought that's just an
interesting
um metaphor for uh for
a couple and for a relationship
where this couple used to be dance
partners they used to literally be in
sync and in step and now they aren't
and therefore they're not able to dance
and what do they
do so for all of them dance and music
becomes
a way that we're able to get a window
into some of their inner workings
that they're that they're experiencing
maria can you talk to me about shooting
this film because it is
so authentically new york how long did
you guys take to
shoot how did you scout locations and
what was that like
yeah so the for about a year i think
that i was in
what i call soft prep where literally i
was going around to
a lot of the locations in my
neighborhood uh that i knew
probably would be in the film um and
just forming relationships with those
business owners
the crew they all teased me because i
would get home in like 10 minutes you
know because everything literally was
in my neighborhood you know but
just i think we shot for like maybe
almost 30 days including the pickups
um roundabout uh but for
while echo was right in the film like we
went through so many drafts
of the film like i think and we had
about 16 drafts of the script
um and as she said she took almost a
year to write it and so little by little
i was just putting things together and
putting things in place because we
didn't know when we first started this
journey
how much support we would get you know
typically there's not a lot of support
out there you know independent film for
this type of story so we
we knew started from the beginning that
we may have to go this alone so
we didn't have money the thing that we
had was time so
you know right from the beginning i
started working in
in soft prep like just with forming
relationships with some of those key
um department heads that i knew like oh
my god if we get this person
i won't have to worry about this
department so i really want to get this
person and just calling them up ahead of
time and you know like just greasing the
wheel like girl how long has it been
since we talked
you know what have you been up to
you know and uh and just little by
little but people i think they just fell
in love with the film like i didn't have
to do
too much convincing of course they loved
us as filmmakers but
again they just loved the story and then
when they read the script echo she did
such an amazing job on the script that
people just felt the heart of it and
also like i said it's a very common
experience like for me like my family
it was incarceration you know like that
separated us
you know for other families it's
immigration you know for other families
it might be
you know because a parent works you know
halfway across the country and only
comes home on the weekends but
you feel like the essence of what it is
it's just about
you know how do you cope with being
separated from the people that you love
you know and so i think when people read
the script they felt the heart of it and
they just wanted to get on board
and of it was really magical honestly
um i was watching onward so you know
that forward is all about magic so i
guess that's what i'm talking about
magic but
it was really magical it was like we
didn't really have a
like the challenges that we had we just
dealt with them and we kept going and
along the way we just kept meeting
folks and and collaborators and vendors
and partners who wanted to help us so
i'm really proud of the film that we
made and i can't wait to release it
we're all excited as well for jamie
natare
and zanab can you all talk about the
family unit that you created on set
because when we first meet your
characters
they couldn't be more part and they
slowly kind of drift back and forth
towards one another as the film presses
on so
either either one of you could talk
about that
i nominate antari thank you
[Laughter]
take it away walter well thank you for
the nomination i'll pass it on to you
next time
i'll pass the baton now this was i felt
i've said this before uh and maybe
that's why zion was asking me to say it
but i was in love with zynab's work
and uh if you ever see her on broadway
or off-broadway
it's just like i was just blown away and
wondered how this person does what they
do
and so for the opportunity to get to
work with her was
such a gift um and so for me i felt like
there's a connection or curiosity or a
window in that i was just
really curious to figure out how she
worked and what it was just
what it was like just to be around her
and equally with jamie i was
stunned just to hear you know
this was her like first job out of
school
because she was such the consummate
professional and
was completely centered and uh so
focused there's a there's that kind of
focus that you have when you're first
right out of school too that's
more intense than anybody else because
you just like i'm just i'm gonna get
this you know
and so i'd see her at the dance
rehearsals and i didn't even know she
was playing my daughter because she was
just so focused on like
doing her dance and i didn't get a
chance to say hello or
and then i realized later you know
because we kept passing each other from
our dance rehearsals oh she's also in
the movie
and i thought she may be a dancer who's
taking dance classes
so that i felt like we were lucky to
have a two-week prep
and echo was is truly the actor's
director
because she did all the work that we
should have done on our own
you know creating music playlists having
us improvise
dialogue what we were like before so she
really created this world for us
uh and because of the chemistry i think
we just
it just sort of we all melded together
um but
maybe you guys feel otherwise i'll let
you speak and see
no that was i mean i was so grateful
again coming straight out of school and
being trained in theater only
to have echo provide two weeks
of of improvising of rehearsal of
figuring out what
our relationship was in the family and
you know even improvising what those
phone calls were over the past 17 years
what
you know all those intimate details i
love that
like i that is like i need
that and um and so that was yeah that
was everything because
we began to all figure out how each
other worked and and then
it made everything easier when we showed
up on set um and like entire said the
chemistry was just there
you know the these are like fantastic
actors to work with
um so yeah it was wonderful too to be
able to just sit down
it's so important that you got to sit
down at that table and
read the script and hear the other
voices
as opposed to the voices in your head
when you read it alone by yourself
just to hear the voices outside of your
head and um
how the you know what they're saying
lands on you and um
i connected with the script initially
reading it just because it's not very
um different from my background i mean i
moved to england when i was like 10 or
10 almost 11. and so i hadn't met my
parents
in that whole time because they were
both at a university in england
and so i was meeting them essentially
for the first time getting to know these
people so
it was wonderful to be able to connect
my own experience
with what was on on the page and also
to be able to look at antare and jamie
and
you know superimpose their their what
they brought to the script
onto what was um in front of me it just
made it so much more concrete and
three-dimensional
so um it made by the time we got to the
set
you know you were just you were just
like the like the dance you're just
following
you know it's give and take it's
responding reaction
so yeah it was great that uh echo did
that yeah
and i that's why i love the ending it's
sort of really open-ended
and nothing's quite resolved but i
wanted to talk to you about how you
decided on that ending and what made you
land there after
16 15 16 renditions of the script
um it's a great question
i mean i think part of it is that
you know we we start it's over
the the beginning of the film feels like
an ending right that's usually like the
ending of the movie's like and then
we're back together yay
um and that's where we begin so
where do you go from there it's it's
almost like a full start because it
really is
it's an ending to their visa issues but
it's the beginning of the rest of their
lives
um and it didn't feel
accurate or realistic that in
the span of three to four weeks you know
which is what we had imagined that the
film would cover
that we'd get to the kind of conclusion
where they're like and then they lived
happily ever after and will never have
problems again
um so i
i felt like what would what felt right
to me
is that we end where they've sort of
made a new
another beginning where they've made the
decision to start again
you know sort of like all right let's
take two
um you know and and if we came back you
know i think one of the things that
hurry and i would say
when we were talking about the film to
people you know
in pre-production is that
if we came back for sql and we saw that
the family was still together
we would be like yeah that's so sweet i
could see them work you know they
really tried this family i could see
that
and if you came back and you didn't find
them together you'd be like you know
what they've really tried like i saw
that family working and they you know so
you can kind of see it go either way
um and it's really up to you to
i guess wonder what what work is gonna
because it's work that
that obviously has to come after that
but they've gotten to a place where they
can agree upon
we're gonna try we're we're gonna make
an attempt we're gonna
start you know the the playing field has
been leveled a little bit better this
time around and so
you know take two let's try again um and
that just felt
more accurate and more real to me
wonderful so i'm gonna open it up to
audience questions now we're all very
excited this song is coming out
friday both on video on demand and
anywhere the theaters are actually open
right now during coven
but the first question comes from
jonathan schwartz he says
i thought the story was very moving and
inspiring did real life experience his
figure into the story and if so how
i think um a number of real life
experiences
colored this story i certainly didn't
document anybody's experience
and transcribe that for the script
um but most of my characters were
influenced or by somebody
or you know by an incident or a person
you know whether it be just kind of
their energy or the kind of person that
they
are um and different thing you know
aunties that i know um who are
uber religious and therefore were able
to sort of inform
um esther's character you know i did
do a lot of research in terms of asking
people about
the work that they do i i interviewed a
nurse for example an er nurse
to like sort of get in the mind of an er
nurse
and the kinds of sacrifices that they
make not only in their work but
how that kind of seeps into their
personal life as well
where they might be making decisions
that aren't particularly great for them
because they're saving other lives um
you know and things like that and you
know for sylvia's character
for you know i was born in the u.s and
left when i was five
and grew up in kenya and then came back
when i was 17 which is about the same
age as sylvia's character
um and for me dance and music were
were my lifelines was sort of like the
way for me to remember who i was and
what was important
and kind of helped me find my voice that
it was a little different i you know i
didn't come from
i english was the first language for me
there was a lot of things that were
different but there were certain things
that i was able to sort of insert
into the script um so
just kind of borrowing bits and pieces
from
from folks but zynga the neighbor um
that was
you know definitely a good friend of
mine who's
queen africa and my hairdresser
people that i met in brooklyn who
you know i you know that character if
you lived in brooklyn you know that
character
and so that was a conglomeration of a
number of people as well
it's so great to see raleigh
she was fabulous fabulous as always
a robin schwartz says what a beautiful
film can you explain the title and how
long did production last
um yeah so you know farewell or more we
had a lot of questions about that
because
as echo mentioned you know the family
they get back together
in the opening scene and so what in the
world why do you call a film farewell
more and for us it was because you know
throughout their journey
these characters they had to be okay
with saying goodbye to
you know who they thought they were who
they thought each other were
and be able to accept you know this is
the reality
of of the situation now it's not about
you know that memory that we had
you know 17 years ago it's not about you
know this perception that we had through
the telephone
and through the skypes and whatever so
it's about like saying goodbye to that
so farewell to that past
and embracing you know what this new
reality is and
and and going off into the future so
that's kind of where the title
um why we stuck with farewell more um
and then uh in terms of how long
production lasts you know
the actual shoot i think was like i said
of maybe four weeks or so
and then we were in post for about
five months uh it was really a really
really quick post
where we had two editors we were living
in dark rooms
for so long because we knew um we wanted
to premiere at the sundance film
festival
and so wrapping up shoot in august you
know
and we actually started editing on day
two of
our of our production so we were editing
in the whole time that we were shooting
um and wrapping up you know the shoot in
august and
rushing through the edit rushing through
color
through sound you know titles it was
like a whirlwind and so when we actually
got to the sundance film festival in
january
it was like we were emerging like oh
there's life out there you know
there's national people you know outside
of these dark rooms and so
uh that's kind of like the summary of uh
the length of production and pulse
and speaking of sundance uh dave berman
asked
what was it like to watch the film with
an audience which is something
we really got lucky to do that at the
top of the year
so that's what everyone wrote was that
like for you all well that's why i
produce producing is like so
challenging it's like you get all the
bumps all the bruises
you cry blood sweat and tears
little like you know fanfare about your
work and what you do
but to be able to sit there and watch it
with an audience it's just
amazing to hear them laugh and you know
feel like they're moved in certain
scenes
and look around and see the tears in the
eyes like that's for me personally
that's why i
actually produced for that moment
i mean it's very special it was also
you know as maria mentioned we literally
i think
we finished the film probably five or
six days before we showed it
and so we had been living in dark rooms
for about three months
and then was in the dark room but all of
a sudden there are all these other
people in the dark room with us
it was a little weird at first
i took some getting used to but
certainly just being able to feel the
the audience's energy was just so
incredible
and to watch it with to watch it with
the cast because it was the first time
they got to see it too
um was really really special yeah i'm
being so nervous i kept trying i was
like
i was trying to sit next to sign up and
um nana cause i was like
so nervous of you know watching it and
then having other people watch it
but um that was just an
unreal that was just so unreal like i've
never
i've never been a part of something like
that before um
been able to watch something that i had
done with an
audience like that that's a crazy
concept to me
um and like like ekwa and haria said
you're hearing all the responses in the
way that people
um uh resonate or relate to
the the characters of the situations and
what
do the audience find funny and what do
they uh get emotional about or where
you know i love a good amen or
so i was listening for those
um and when you could get i mean it was
just it was
it was true that was like one of the
best things uh about sundance
just hearing that first crowd respond
it was so surreal wasn't it because i'd
never been there it's my first time
there so i was like
oh my god so this is what it's all about
i've heard about this place on this
festival so it was surreal
and wonderful and nerve-wracking too to
see it
just put on the big screen and everyone
you know and revisiting those moments
that seemed so far away
so long ago and then you're looking at
it going oh god
yeah i remember that ah half of me
wanted to hide the chairs behind
in front of me i actually was trying to
slip under because i have a hard time
looking at myself on screen
so it was like jamie was going come sit
over here and i'm like i can't move
[Laughter]
so but that was exciting because it was
both our first time so it was like ah
it was wonderful but i can't wait to do
it again
it'll be great right to go back it's not
going to be prepared
what about you sorry um what did you
think about watching this
i just wish had been at that
i mean for these guys what they're
talking about just to have that
experience firsthand
but i think we were all totally blown
away by the response that joi
got i think she got the loudest
audible response yes the scenes got the
loudest audible response
at every screening it was like
you know why jesus and then the house
and just go down
i i really i feel i i and i mean
we sent a message to join that night a
video message
but it didn't translate of course
because i was like oh man
i wish he could have seen it yeah
even now with the pandemic we're in you
just
understand how valuable how rich and how
what a great opportunity it is to be
able to commune
uh with a piece of art like this and
experience it together
absolutely timmy ojo says this is for
equa
when esther was cleaning up and setting
up the house she puts up a fish symbol
on the wall
but flips flipped upside down however
near the end
we'll see the symbol upright correctly
all this was in the background
and it was easy to miss what was the
intention symbolizing the
displacement of her faith and the
eventual clarity she obtained
or was it pure scent dressing and
coincidence
i'm so amazed that you cut that because
i didn't
um
but i i'm wondering if that was either
like set dressing or if that like i'm
wondering if we flipped
the um the image at some point
in edit um and i don't remember but
um that was not intentional
um but i'm glad that it means something
to you
we planned that all along right right
right
we're deep you know what i mean i was
about to be really impressed if y'all
had planned that out
like that the inner workings
it was my fault i was playing with
things with the fish i thought let me
just
show esther's
that's great as i know we spoke about
this briefly
as well but jim cram jen cramer also
wants to know
about the three different perspectives
and can you talk a little bit about
being inspired by that choice and she
says thank you so much for this
extraordinary film
thank you um i will also say that i'm a
i'm a great lover of the show the affair
um and you know one of the things that i
love about the affair was just
how you know each person
would have an experience but you know my
my reading of the experience is
completely different from the other
person's reading
and you know we didn't have the time
resources or energy to go
as deeply as they did in the affair in
terms of having a different wardrobe and
this that and the other
didn't quite work for our script but
that was definitely one of the
inspirations for me in terms of you know
just the
the question of um
seeing the seeing an issue
from different perspectives you know we
all have our own
ideas and our own um assumptions
about particular things about whether
walter's
guilty or not you know whether he should
have done it or not whether esther
should be as religious as she is whether
sylvia should be you know more
subordinate or less rude or
less quiet you know whatever the case is
um
and until you're in that person's shoes
you can't really tell you know or you
can only tell what you know and
where you're from because you're judging
it from your own perspective
um and so wanting to be able to
um kind of challenge those ideas a
little bit
by by showing more perspectives and and
then
and then that you make a conclusion from
there as to how you feel about these
characters
and i will say that the three you know
the three
perspectives did get a lot of i wouldn't
use the word pushback but there was a
lot of questions about it from with our
collaborators like
you know we went through a couple of
different labs and they were like
oh i think you should just tell the
story linearly
you know like i went through the
producing lab and it was like oh
maybe you guys should tell the story
linearly and i was like well you need to
tell that to equal because
because she is very committed you know
to
uh to these perspectives the way that it
is you know and then i think as the
script
matured and that's the script developed
then it was like no this is working
and then even in post you know some of
our producing partners were like
i think we should edit this let's just
try to edit it linearly you know and we
knew that that was not going to work
because it was not shot that way
you know um and it would just make a
mess of things
but we did it just to show them like
okay you wanted to see it this is what
this looks like
linearly you know um and it was like oh
no no go back to the way that you guys
had it and we were like thank you
again how did you and this is from um
dana
and they asked how did you go about
casting this film everyone was
exceptional by the way
oh well that's you know to we just you
know i think
to their credit you know all these
actors they did just an amazing job
um and i think to aqua's credit she
wrote just amazing characters you know
i always say that it starts on the page
and if you give
you know actors something really amazing
to work with and then you couple that
with some amazing actors that's going to
be really great but we worked with a
cast of director named rebecca dealey
from christy street casting and she's
just like
everything i love me some rebecca dilly
um and she gave
us phenomenal choices you know um but
you could you could speak a little bit
more about about that yeah
i loved working with rebecca because she
was able to really hone in on what it is
that i was trying to say
for the script and actually in some
parts
where you know i wasn't seeing what i
wanted from you know the actors who came
in and i was like oh what are we missing
and she would explain to me what the
script was which was
very illuminating for me to be like oh i
didn't know it was that
you know i remember her um asking her
about the esther part and you know there
were
people who were just kind of doing one
thing but not doing the other thing and
i was like
what why are we struggling so much with
this and she's like it's actually a very
layered
part that you've written and you may not
realize it because you know you're just
sort of like
putting things on pages but it's very
it's not everybody who can actually get
all of those things and that is what we
found with zynab
so it was it was an easy pick with zion
because she was the one person who
came in was able to hit all the marks
very smoothly and
kind of sit like that afterwards and be
like bam what's up
um becca's great with explaining things
to actors i've gone into
i've gone to visit her oh gone in for
her a few times and
she's always so good at just really like
she's read the script
she has an understanding of it and she
really will just point out what it is
the director is looking for even if the
director herself hasn't decided at that
point so
you know she'll bring up um things that
you may not have thought about but she
knows
how to hit those notes in an actor and
especially she's familiar with you
and i'm familiar with her she's familiar
with my work so it's great to go in for
her because
you're comfortable personally you're
comfortable they don't make you
she puts you at ease and then she
because you're at ease you're able to
really
listen to what it is that they're
looking for
and incorporate that into your your
performance you take notes
and that's the one thing i love about
rebecca she really knows how to put you
at ease so you can just like do the work
instead of doing other business with
nonsense nerves and all that just
she just pinpoints what needs to be done
yeah
she's really smart that way um and just
able to see
i mean even with the nzinga character we
had seen a lot of younger nzingas
who you know played it a very particular
way which was funny
but it wasn't quite what it wasn't quite
work it worked better on
page than what you know than what we
were seeing
and again it was like oh rebecca what do
we do and she was like you know you
might want to consider somebody
older you know a character who's a
little bit older have you thought of joi
and i was like oh yes draw would be
great and brought her in and it was
exactly what we needed
and really she hit the mark on every
single person that she brought in was
just like
let me help you
this is who you need to be talking to
it's really lovely and we knew casting
you know walter
and casting sylvia would be challenging
because of the fact that
um you have to speak with an accent you
i mean you have to be able to deliver
the accent
and you also have to be able to dance
you know um
and you know working with our financiers
just speaking from that side of things
you know a lot of times they just want
you know names
like oh yeah this guy that was on this
poster when i was driving down the
freeway that's so you know
it's like no oh that's not gonna work
here you know what i mean
and we would have a very very different
movie um and not as
lovely a movie you know if you just
sometimes just cast for like the biggest
freaking
you know and so we just i it was just
managing that expectation so that we
could actually
cast who we wanted to cast to deliver
a really amazing film and we were so
lucky that we got atari and jamie
um before we wrap our last question is
if you are able to share what other
projects are you all currently working
on
anybody want to go first
oh mom's the word over here okay um
i mean i'm not able to share but um i do
have a project
that um i'm lined up for and it's um
it's a different project it's a period
piece um it's set in the 50s it's an
african-american
family um and i'm very excited to be
working on it it's actually a very huge
privilege and
hopefully i'll get to talk about it more
in the coming months
i know everybody's like
[Music]
i'm working on going on vacation that's
my next project
amen i'm working on going on holiday
somewhere hot and sunny and tropical
that's a wonderful project yes on that
one
yeah i have another film that's actually
coming out
in early next year i think january
february it's a very similar story
but i play the religious parent in this
one
ah but it's literally a story about
uh a father who brings his family
to the states um but he brings his son
it's a son
and he literally does step dance
um for a fraternity wow it's like
crazy parallels something's in the water
yeah so that will be coming out it's
called tasmanian devil and then i have a
new series
coming out on netflix which they haven't
announced so i can't i can't
say what it is but i just feel grateful
that you know to have some stuff
given the challenging times we're all in
yeah
and then i'm reading a bunch of scripts
um echo and i both are we get so many
scripts sent to us
all the time um to work on so there's
some stuff that's really
peaking our interest and peaking my
interest and then also i'm writing i'm
spending a lot of time
doing this quarantine writing which has
been really really cool so
i'm excited about some of the projects
that i'm writing
well thank you all so very much for this
gorgeous spellman for chatting with us
today
farewell or more will be out this friday
december the 11th
on video on demand and anywhere that you
can go to the movies
or drive in so thank you so much this
was such a wonderful discussion